[Music]
took a nice little journey off-road
16 kilometers from the main road
it's a very bumpy ride but
at the end it pays off something
really magnificent to see
it's kind of isolated and away
from everything else it's broken
it's really
a beautiful serene
sight to see
and you guys are getting to see it here
beautiful marshall
[Music]
it reminds me it's another example of
many of the gems that are out there the
things that are of value are kind of
hidden
and this is
one of those gems it's hidden
it's somewhere where you have to
make an effort and go through
a little bit of a
journey to find it
but when you find it it was well worth
defined
it's a beautiful hidden gem
alhamdulillah
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see down yeah where we came
from there's no snow
but up here in the mountains there's
snow
underground water that's how it's filled
people come to stay up here
you can actually wake up
here in a nice cabin home and come out
to this beautiful
serene view
in bosnia
oh
[Music]
you're pretty much on fire
get your candles and uh
disconnect from the
city life
see you guys beautiful
when you come in
over here
you see this beautiful forest
[Music]
is
[Music]
do you think people are
are more
engaged with themselves like with their
internal selves when they disconnect
from
the material world and they come out
here how do you feel when you're out
here first thing i feel
i feel we're very small
this is why with
what breaks this ego inside you and then
right away you feel like just one
creation of god
between many many more amazing
and big
and nice creations of god like what we
can see
this big lake huge mountains
tall trees
so when you see this there's no
creations
better
and nicer than god's creations and then
when you come close to them then you
feel this peace you feel this
calmness there is no
rush there is no
chaos what we have in the city and then
you just start asking yourself why we
went for the series in the first place
that's why many learned people
many scholars of islam they recommend
and this is i mean for anybody you don't
have to be a muslim it's just to
disconnect disconnect from the tall
buildings and
the rat race of life and into
yeah the concrete jungle and to come out
to uh places like this uh maybe you
won't get an opportunity
like this but you know just to get out
uh you know maybe even a forest preserve
if that's the closest and then to
reflect like why am i here
who created me where am i going when i
die and at what point in your life did
you start asking those questions because
you weren't always someone who was
implementing the purpose of life
i would wish maybe to be coming from
that
corner but
alhamdulillah i came from the other side
i was actually i lived in us
that's why i can speak english
so i saw the opposite
u.s
showed me the total
opposite of what is the purpose of life
and i'm not saying that people in us are
bad or evil or anything i just said that
this bad system and bad trend
is mostly developed in u.s so when i
when i went from bosnia i went there and
i saw this huge
turn of of lack of morality of
lack of values which do exist in bosnia
just to be clear but it's much much more
developed and all of the world is
following this western way of life and i
had a chance to taste it first hand and
just to see how empty and how bad it is
and this actually made me reflect and
think about okay if you if i see these
bad values like so clearly now because
it was extreme change for me
then i have to think about other values
and then i start thinking about islam
which was alhamdulillah my origin but
that's first time i started evaluating
okay why xena bad why is alcohol bad
because it leads
to all these promiscuities and lack of
values and
just being lost so that's in short
what's triggered this
this quest for truth alhamdulillah led
to islam
[Music]
and we're thinking about
i'm thinking about taking the
challenge of uh
it's not the ideal weather it's not that
cold but
i've been doing a lot of the
cold showers so
some cold water therapy some call it
so maybe i'm thinking about jumping in
but uh
what we were talking about about
anything that the creator
allah had had prohibited one of those
things you mentioned alcohol we and
that's one of the wisdoms
is uh because it's harmful not just for
the individual but for society and
humanity and we were we were talking
about
how
they were telling us that
there was a death
here not too long ago how long was that
two or three months ago yeah and it was
due to the person
flipping over in a boat and the
individual was a two or one there were
four there was four they were drunk on
the boat drunk
and so you see what happens you start
drinking
your mind starts getting you know
they were playing around like rock kings
a little boat they flipped over and
sadly one died three of them
they
survived they got a chance to to get
there it's very sad to hear that
but you see where
these things are there for wisdom
so anything like gambling alcohol
fornication
adultery all of these things that have a
really
bad impact on society and even for the
individual's life those things are
are
prohibited in islam
so zero's freezing
they're saying it's uh
about six
degrees above freezing but
in the water
down below it's
it's supposed to be frozen
inshallah
we'll see
but uh
to hear that
people
a couple months ago drowns
someone
died
that uh
adds a little bit to the nerves huh
and shalom
let's see what happens you smell
[Music]
it's cold
what do you have to say
nice
the practice was worth it yeah very cold
so they told us during the summer it was
six degrees celsius but now
the winter is approaching and you can
see the snow
around the lake so
that suggests that it might be even
under six degrees celsius
[Music]
alhamdulillah we got some cold water
therapy
many health benefits look it up
but you can see out here how just how
cold
okay the water i mean you can see
there's snow up here look
and then we're also
i talked about this before you can look
it up i did a video show on grounding
where you connect
with uh the earth here
so you walk in barefoot
and then i
related that to the to the sajdah that
we do five times a day
we're putting our forehead
to the ground grounding ourselves
and uh you can check out the video i did
on that
about the address and we'll continue on
our journey here in bosnia
taking you on a tour
of
inside
from
yeah outside of a
couple of hours from
the main capital sarajevo
you have a nice look
here
they're
restricted to my
housing with the original
wood
so to keep this look going
yeah and do a quick
these things that i that i talk about my
episodes
is very important take take a look uh
type in cold water showers you can start
at home doing it and just look at the
benefits of it
now who likes to take cold showers i
mean obviously
i would like to keep it
hot warm but if there's benefits to
something
why not if it's going to help reduce
inflammation
you follow me straighten your immune
system
you follow me and it's proven to do that
why not do it you suffer a little bit uh
discomfort but for a greater gain at the
end you following me
yeah so look into it cold water benefits
and
and i also have a link to the to the
grounding
that i talked about before
which we actually do i mean it's amazing
it's a lot so if you make us a lot
make sure
you start to get up to it
start to get up to those
five times a day prayers
that is nourishment for the soul
now we're on a mission
to find some more
real milk
unpasteurized un homogenized
chemical free
straight how
the creator intended
for us to
to drink it now when you i this is
another thing i really encourage you to
investigate to look into this is on my
journey of drinking
real milk was
back when they had
unsanitary conditions
they had alcohol bins distilleries and
the milk got contaminated and that's
where they developed this heating method
but now
if the milk the cow is a you first of
all to drink the milk from these
industrial
uh farming
institutions it's very unhealthy the
cows are sick they don't see the light
of day
um
they eat what they're not supposed to be
eating but grass-fed cows
they're in a healthy environment
this is how allah
this is how the crater
intended it for us to drink
and there's a miracle actually
uh there's the mention in the quran
that god almighty allah talks about
isn't that amazing that between the
feces
and the blood
you would think like how would a man
1400 years ago
come up with this
you would expect through feces the milk
would come out there'd be some stench
right
of the feces or
through the blood the mixture
there would be some
some red spots of blood but no god
almighty allah talks about that it comes
out pure and palatable
to drink right there's no smell of blood
feces or even drops
any kind
of blood
in that this is one of the
one of the um
signs as we call it
this book the quran could never have
come
from a human being a group of humans but
it's indeed from the creator of the
heavens and earth so let's go find some
raw milk real milk as allah intended for
us to drink
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that
[Music]